especially because we're all like in our  early 20s like this is the time to like  explore and find yourself too when you  say explore and find yourself does that  mean just like get run through by a  bunch of dudes  I'm just translating  the correct answer is yes that's what  they meant I will say it is a double  standard when people say why am I a [ __ ]  if I do this and men aren't okay  that is true here's why you're the  gatekeeper women you control access to  sex right because your natural set point  is no I don't know prove your worth a  man's natural set point is please can we  all acknowledge that not most women are  [ __ ]  but some are  now if you're just going on your and  you're going into it with the mindset of  I am going to sleep around I this  because it's my 20s  some women are and we'd like to thank  your dad